[Music]
this is your Tech news briefing for
Monday March 20th I'm Zoe Thomas for The
Wall Street Journal
Tick Tock CEO show Chu is scheduled to
testify before Congress on Thursday
lawmakers want to know about possible
National Security risks posed by the
app's owner beijing-based bite dance it
comes as the Biden Administration last
week threatened to ban Tick-Tock in the
U.S if it's Chinese owners don't sell
their stakes in the company and
lawmakers in several Western countries
and in States across the U.S have
already barred Tick-Tock from government
devices but there's another push against
Tick Tock this one from Silicon Valley
Executives and U.S lawmakers quietly
mobilizing against Chinese involvement
in the U.S tech sector with me to
discuss this new alliance is our Tech
reporter Georgia Wells hi Georgia thanks
for joining me oh thank you Zoe so tell
me about this group that's making a push
against China in the U.S tech sector so
I've been reporting on a group of
Silicon Valley Tech people who are
Venture capitalists found vendors
Executives who are partnering with
lawmakers in Washington DC to mobilize
on their concerns about China and for
many of them Tick Tock is the top of
their list of things they worry about
and they're actually meeting up next
week for a secret dinner in Washington
to discuss their concerns about Tick
Tock the this dinner occurs the night
before tick tocks CEO testifies on
Capitol Hill so in their view their
Prime in Congress to be ready for this
testimony
who are the big names behind this group
so the organizer is a relative newcomer
his name is Jacob Helberg and he's the
newest member of the U.S China economic
and Security review commission they're a
congressional research and advisory
panel but his roots are in the tech
world he was in policy at Google for a
while and so he has partnered up with
Venture capitalists to make this event
happen and they have really big name
speakers and including Peter Thiel and
vinod khosla who are both very
well-known Venture capitalists in
Silicon Valley
all right tell me a bit more about this
dinner apart from those big name
speakers who else do we expect to be
there
so the list includes a number of
lawmakers it reads like who's who of the
folks in Congress who have actually
introduced legislation targeting Tech
talk or foreign adversaries and so some
of the expected attendees include
Senator Marco Rubio senator Mark Warner
representative Michael McCall
representative Mike Gallagher Senator
Corey Booker like a really broad list of
lawmakers right it sounds like both
sides of the aisle there it's uniquely
bipartisan and also uniquely bi-coastal
in the groups that's bringing together
some of the people I spoke with said
that they actually believe that that is
the strength of this group and that it's
bringing together
so many people who don't have a whole
lot in common but who all have anxiety
about the role of China in Tech
competition between the two countries
what exactly are their concerns so
venture capitalist vinod khosla he's
described a broader techno-economic war
between the US and China and he really
sees that in 20 years he believes the
war for economic dominance and then
political power is really up in the air
the lawmakers attending many of them
have described to me two concerns about
Tick Tock it's
user data so the concern that the
Chinese government could lean on bite
dance which is Tick tock's parent
company to hand over data about American
users so that's one major concern and
the other is about the Chinese
government's ability to lean on bike
dance to influence the content that
users American users see on Tick Tock so
those are the two main concerns that
lawmakers have outlined and what's tick
tock's response to that so Tick Tock has
outlined this more than a billion
dollars the company has spent in this
new structure called project Texas
in which Tick Tock would house the
sensitive data around American users In
This Cloud ecosystem controlled by
Oracle and so tick tock's response to
lawmakers when they voice these concerns
is that this structure should address
those concerns what about Jacob Helberg
why is he involved with this so he
described to me his the evolution of his
views on China and many of them appeared
to begin back in 2016 when he was
working on policy at Google where he was
looking at kind of the company's ability
to to combat foreign interference on its
platform in 2016 if you recall that was
when
pro-russia groups use U.S internet
platforms like Google Facebook Twitter
to so Discord ahead of the US
presidential election and he said when
he was at Google he observed that Russia
although it was the most prominent
foreign interference effort that he
observed that China's efforts were all
actually not that far behind and so
reflecting on his time at Google in his
book the wires of War he wrote about his
views of a coming cyber war between the
U.S and China is how he described it
Georgia Georgia these are Silicon Valley
Executives and investors what have their
interactions with China been like over
the last few years
so part of what's interesting here is
that many Tech players in Silicon Valley
View China with frustration because they
see the two countries of having an
asymmetric relationship around Tech and
so what they mean by that is that it's
been very very hard for U.S tech
companies particularly consumer internet
companies to operate in China so for
example like Google Twitter Facebook
Instagram Snapchat like those are not
accessible for people in China unless
they use special tools to kind of
Disguise their locations meanwhile
though like Tick Tock is an example of
the biggest Chinese Tech hit of all time
to make it big in the US and so many of
the Silicon Valley Tech entrepreneurs
who I speak with that feel frustration
that Chinese tech companies can access
the US when they cannot access China so
that's also a part of what's setting the
stage for the kind of Dynamics we're
seeing at play here all right that's our
reporter Georgia Wells thanks for
joining us Georgia Thank You Zoe all
right that's it for Tech news briefing
today but a quick note before we close
the show we're still taking your
questions about generative AI For an
upcoming episode AI programs like chat
GPT Microsoft's new Bing search or mid
journey and we're going to answer them
on an upcoming episode do you want to
know more about how these AI programs
work or maybe how this latest wave of AI
development could change how we live our
lives
leave us a voicemail with your AI
question at
415-439-6482 or send us a voice
recording to tnb wsj.com
I'm Zoe Thomas for The Wall Street
Journal thanks for listening
[Music]